as you can see I did receive my Academy  booklet on how to dress like a serious  actress nominated for Best Performance  by an actor in a supporting role our Don  Ameche in cocoon  Klaus Maria Brandauer in Out of Africa  Nikki and [ __ ] on  robert loggia in the jagged-edged  Eric Robertson runaway train  Don Ameche and cocoon  it would please me very much if everyone  that made a creative contribution to  cocoon would stand here with me in  spirit because they deserve to be here  and to them I give my deep deep thanks  to all you members of the Academy this  esteemed gentleman here says that you  have given to me your recognition you've  given to me your love you have given to  me and I hope I've earned your respect  for all these I am deeply grateful thank  you